This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the Tempelhof-Schöneberg district of Berlin, there's an enormous concrete structure that sits across the street from a supermarket. It's obscured by trees, surrounded by residential apartments, and gently flecked with German graffiti. Okay, check 1212. It is 834 a.m. I am quite possibly the most jet-lagged I've ever been in my entire life And I'm waiting for my uber or as they say here in Germany my uber We sent 99 PI producer Vivian Lay there to check it out Jet lag be damned I met up with Hana Fisha and Vincent Brookman Hana is the curator and deputy director for the Templehof-Schöneberg Museums, and Vincent is a journalist and tour guide.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在柏林的滕珀尔霍夫-舍内贝格区，有一座巨大的混凝土建筑，它坐落在一家超市的马路对面。它被树木遮挡，周围环绕着居民公寓，表面零星点缀着德国涂鸦。好的，试音1212。现在是早上8点34分。我可能正处于人生中最严重的时差反应中，我正在等我的优步，或者像德国人说的那样，我的“优步”。我们派了《99 PI》的制作人薇薇安·莱去那里一探究竟。管他什么时差，我见到了汉娜·菲莎和文森特·布鲁克曼。汉娜是滕珀尔霍夫-舍内贝格博物馆的馆长兼副馆长，文森特是一位记者兼导游。
They were there to show me around a curious neighborhood landmark. From afar, it kind of looks like a derelict, brutalist grain silo. Is it a popular site for people to visit, this one? Yes, the Templehof-Schöneberg is the most popular. And it is the least aesthetically pleasing. Yeah, that is true. This structure is a bit hard to describe because there's literally nothing else like it in the world. On the surface, it's a very, very big, very, very heavy cylindrical block of solid concrete
他们带我参观了这个奇特的地标。从远处看，它看起来像是一个废弃的粗野主义粮仓。这是人们常去参观的景点吗？是的，滕珀尔霍夫-舍内贝格是这里最受欢迎的。而且它在审美上是最不讨喜的。是的，确实如此。这座建筑有点难以描述，因为世界上真的没有其他类似的东西。从表面上看，它是一个非常、非常大，非常、非常重的圆柱形实心混凝土块。
about the height of a four-story building. This concrete, 12,650, I think, tons of concrete. And sitting underneath those 12,650 tons of concrete is a narrow chamber about eight feet in diameter that descends 60 feet into the ground. There's a ladder here that we can't use now, unfortunately, and then it goes, I think, 18 meters into the ground. Have you guys ever crawled down there?
大约有四层楼那么高。这块混凝土，我想有12650吨重。在那12650吨混凝土下面，是一个直径约8英尺的狭窄空间，向下延伸了60英尺。这里有个梯子，可惜我们现在不能用，它向下延伸了，我想是18米深。你们爬下去过吗？
No, not allowed. This entire structure was designed to test the soil in this area of Berlin. That chamber was once an observation area where researchers measured how the soil below was responding to the pressure exerted by the weight of the cylinder on top of it. Whether the cylinder itself was shifting, sinking into the ground, exciting stuff like that. People from all over the world come to Berlin to see what is essentially an abandoned soil testing research tool. And the name of this unusual tourist site
不，不允许。整个建筑的设计初衷是为了测试柏林这一地区的土壤。那个空间曾经是一个观测区，研究人员在那里测量下方的土壤如何应对上方圆柱体重量所施加的压力。比如圆柱体本身是否在移动、是否在下沉等等。来自世界各地的人们来到柏林，就是为了看这个本质上已经废弃的土壤测试研究工具。而这个不同寻常的旅游景点的名字，
is just about as easy to pronounce as it is to describe. In German, it's Schwerbelastungskörper. And in English, then it's the heavy load bearing body. Does it make sense in English? Not entirely. The Schwerbelastungskörper is kind of a tongue twister. But luckily, there's a few other simpler nicknames for it. The cylinder, the concrete cylinder, the concrete mushroom,
和它的描述一样难以发音。德语叫Schwerbelastungskörper。翻译成英语就是“重载承重体”。在英语里说得通吗？不完全是。Schwerbelastungskörper简直是个绕口令。但幸运的是，它还有几个更简单的绰号。圆柱体、混凝土圆柱体、混凝土蘑菇，
because it sort of looks like a mushroom. But locals in the area have referred to it by a much more nefarious nickname. It used to be the nickname Nazi Klotz. A klotz is like a heavy kind of stone that you put onto something, and Nazi, so it's kind of like Nazi block. The Nazi block. The Schwerba-Lastingskörper is not famous for what it does, but who built it. This big, crumbling piece of concrete was actually the first step in a monstrous urban
因为它看起来有点像蘑菇。但当地人给它起了一个更邪恶的绰号。它曾经被称为“纳粹块”（Nazi Klotz）。Klotz是指那种压在某物上的沉重石块，加上纳粹，所以就像是“纳粹块”。这个“纳粹块”之所以出名，不是因为它的功能，而是因为建造它的人。这块巨大、正在崩塌的混凝土，实际上是阿道夫·希特勒构想的一个庞大城市规划方案的第一步。
planning scheme, dreamed up by Adolf Hitler. Thankfully, that plan never materialized. Now, this Nazi block is one of the only remaining monuments to the Third Reich's most colossal architectural failure. There was a phrase that leaders in the Third Reich said about architecture, that it was Worte aus Stein, or Words in Stone. It means that architecture has a specific ability to bypass language and reasoning, to have a direct impact on a person's emotions.
谢天谢地，那个计划从未实现。现在，这个“纳粹块”是第三帝国最宏大的建筑失败案例中仅存的纪念碑之一。第三帝国的领导人曾用一个短语来形容建筑，即“石之言”（Worte aus Stein）。这意味着建筑有一种特殊的能力，可以绕过语言和理性，直接影响一个人的情绪。
If you've ever walked into a family friend's farmhouse-style home and immediately felt a sense of coziness, or had your breath taken away while standing at the top of the Empire State Building, then you know exactly what I'm talking about. Architecture can move you and shape your actions in ways that you aren't even aware of. Hitler not only understood this innate power about architecture, he weaponized it. When we think about architecture and weaponization, especially around the Third Reich. You might think about the Atlantic Wall or bomb shelters. This is Despina Stratagakis, an architectural historian at the University at Buffalo.
如果你曾走进一位熟人的农舍风格住宅，并立刻感到一种舒适感，或者在帝国大厦顶端感到屏息凝神，那么你就明白我在说什么了。建筑可以以你甚至没有意识到的方式打动你并塑造你的行为。希特勒不仅理解建筑的这种内在力量，他还将其武器化了。当我们想到建筑和武器化，特别是围绕第三帝国时，你可能会想到大西洋壁垒或防空洞。这是布法罗大学的建筑历史学家德斯皮娜·斯特拉塔加基斯。
But there are a lot of ways in which architecture can be instrumentalized for ideological purposes that are not maybe as obvious, but that can be very powerful. Hitler was infatuated with art and architecture, enough that he was famously rejected from art school a couple of times. Even early on, he spoke openly about the ways architecture and power are intertwined. If you look at Mein Kampf, and I hope you won't, but if you want to torture yourself, in Mein Kampf, he writes about the importance of architecture and particularly the importance of architecture to create the Volksgemeinschaft.
但建筑在很多方面都可以被工具化以达到意识形态目的，这些方式可能不那么明显，但却非常强大。希特勒对艺术和建筑非常痴迷，以至于他曾两次被艺术学校拒绝，这很有名。即使在早期，他也公开谈论建筑与权力是如何交织在一起的。如果你看《我的奋斗》，我希望你不会看，但如果你想折磨自己，在《我的奋斗》中，他写到了建筑的重要性，特别是建筑对于创造“人民共同体”（Volksgemeinschaft）的重要性。
And the Volksgemeinschaft is this absolutely central concept in national socialism. It is the racially unified community. The Volksgemeinschaft literally translates to people's community. And the concept was central to Hitler's racist and anti-Semitic ideology. It claimed that there was a, quote, racial hierarchy, which there isn't, and a, quote, ideal way of German life. Again, which there isn't. Look, Hitler was an ahistorical idiot who made a number of false assertions.
“人民共同体”是国家社会主义中一个绝对核心的概念。它是一个种族统一的社区。“Volksgemeinschaft”字面意思是“人民的社区”。这个概念是希特勒种族主义和反犹太主义意识形态的核心。它声称存在一种所谓的“种族等级制度”（实际上并不存在），以及一种所谓的“理想的德国生活方式”（同样不存在）。听着，希特勒是个无视历史的白痴，他提出了许多错误的断言。
One of them was that the ancient Roman Empire represented the peak of human civilization and that Germans were, quote, racial ancestors of the Romans and therefore at the top of that hierarchy. Which they aren't. Hitler's looking in particular at ancient Rome and more specifically at the public buildings, the state buildings of ancient Rome, the temples, the baths, the Colosseum. And he says that in its great monuments, a culture expresses its most profound values, it shapes the folks' mindshaft, and also he's thinking about the things that will remain when everything else fades away.
其中之一是古罗马帝国代表了人类文明的巅峰，而德国人是罗马人的所谓“种族祖先”，因此处于等级制度的顶端。而事实并非如此。希特勒特别关注古罗马，更具体地说是古罗马的公共建筑、国家建筑、神庙、浴场、斗兽场。他说，在一个文化的伟大纪念碑中，它表达了其最深刻的价值观，它塑造了“人民共同体”，而且他也在思考当其他一切都消失时，什么会留下来。
And he says wars come and go, but it is the art and the architecture of a civilization that remains. So he's thinking about this long before he gets into power. In 1933, Hitler was appointed Chancellor of Germany and finally had the political power he needed to create these monuments. He just needed an architect to actually build them. Could you tell me a little bit about Albert Speer? How many hours would you like? This is Magnus Brechtgen, Deputy Director of the Institute for Contemporary History in Munich.
他说战争来来去去，但留存下来的是一个文明的艺术和建筑。所以他在掌权之前很久就在思考这个问题。1933年，希特勒被任命为德国总理，终于拥有了创造这些纪念碑所需的政治权力。他只需要一位建筑师来真正建造它们。你能跟我讲讲阿尔伯特·斯佩尔吗？你想听几个小时？这是慕尼黑当代历史研究所副所长马格努斯·布雷希特根。
Albert Speer was a highly ambitious young architect. He was the son of an architect. His father made a lot of money. His mother had a lot of money. So Albert Speer was completely financially independent. He could do whatever he want.
阿尔伯特·斯佩尔是一位雄心勃勃的年轻建筑师。他是一位建筑师的儿子。他父亲赚了很多钱。他母亲也很有钱。所以阿尔伯特·斯佩尔在经济上完全独立。他可以做任何他想做的事。
And what he wanted was the resources and backing of the Nazi Party. Speer was sufficiently talented as an architect, but it was his charm and ruthless ambition that landed him in Hitler's orbit. Albert Speer would magically appear whenever Hitler was coming to do a tour of the construction site. A few minutes beforehand, there was Speer, and he would join the architects and the patron, and they would walk around the site. The workmen would just kind of make
而他想要的是纳粹党的资源和支持。斯佩尔作为建筑师很有才华，但正是他的魅力和冷酷的野心让他进入了希特勒的圈子。每当希特勒来视察工地时，阿尔伯特·斯佩尔总会神奇地出现。提前几分钟，斯佩尔就会在那里，他会加入建筑师和赞助人的行列，一起在工地上走动。工人们只会拿这个年轻的跟班开玩笑。
jokes about this young hanger on. But Speer was there to learn. He was there to learn and to figure out what it was that Hitler wanted, what he liked, what he didn't like, and to be noticed. Speer was still a relatively young man when he had a streak of good luck. Hitler's top architect suddenly dropped dead. At 28 years old, Speer was launched into the position of chief architect for the Third Reich. Hitler apparently loved pageantry and Speer was launched into the position of Chief Architect for the Third Reich. Hitler apparently loved pageantry, and Speer was more than happy to cater to his theatrical whims.
但斯佩尔在那里是为了学习。他去那里是为了学习并弄清楚希特勒想要什么，他喜欢什么，不喜欢什么，并引起注意。斯佩尔还很年轻时就走运了。希特勒的首席建筑师突然暴毙。28岁时，斯佩尔被提拔为第三帝国的首席建筑师。希特勒显然热爱排场，而斯佩尔非常乐意迎合他那些戏剧性的突发奇想。
He was tasked with staging the notorious Cathedral of Light display at the Nuremberg Rally Grounds and designing a new Reich Chancellery. Soon after, Hitler entrusted Speer with his most ambitious design project yet. He wants a capital that is architecturally worthy of being the center of a global empire. In 1937, Hitler declared five cities as, quote, fewer cities, which meant that five cities, Berlin, Nuremberg, Munich, Hamburg, and Linz, would all become cultural capitals in a future Nazi-dominated Europe. Each city would offer its own special contribution towards the Third Reich. Linz, Hitler's favorite city, would become the center of culture.
他负责筹划纽伦堡集会场上臭名昭著的“光之大教堂”展示，并设计了新的帝国总理府。不久之后，希特勒将他迄今为止最雄心勃勃的设计项目交给了斯佩尔。他想要一个在建筑上配得上成为全球帝国中心的首都。1937年，希特勒宣布了五座“元首城市”，这意味着柏林、纽伦堡、慕尼黑、汉堡和林茨都将成为未来纳粹统治下的欧洲的文化之都。每座城市都将为第三帝国做出自己特殊的贡献。林茨，希特勒最喜欢的城市，将成为文化中心。
Munich would be the Nazi party headquarters. Nuremberg would be the city of Nazi party rallies. Hamburg would be the capital of putting a piece of meat between two pieces of bread. Berlin would hold the highest title of them all. Hitler believed that Berlin would become the capital of his quote, greater Germanic Reich and the Nazi seat of power to the rest of the world. But there was one glaring problem with Berlin carrying that particular title.
慕尼黑将是纳粹党总部。纽伦堡将是纳粹党集会之城。汉堡将是把肉放在两片面包之间的首都。柏林将拥有所有称号中最高贵的一个。希特勒相信柏林将成为他所谓的“大德意志帝国”的首都，也是纳粹对世界其他地方的权力中心。但柏林拥有这个特定称号有一个明显的问题。
Hitler did not like Berlin at all. This is Paul Keurig, assistant professor and postdoctoral fellow at the University of Michigan. Hitler understood that Berlin was an important city to the cause of national socialism. It was the capital city of Germany and a cultural center populated by millions of people. But for Hitler, that culture was all wrong. Berlin was, in the Weimar Republic, became known in the 1920s as this kind of really progressive city with a lot of cabaret and people were kind of experimenting with different identities and sexualities and it was very decadent.
希特勒一点也不喜欢柏林。这是密歇根大学助理教授兼博士后研究员保罗·库里格。希特勒明白柏林对国家社会主义事业很重要。它是德国的首都，是一个拥有数百万人口的文化中心。但对希特勒来说，那种文化完全是错误的。在魏玛共和国时期，柏林在20世纪20年代被称为那种非常进步的城市，有很多歌舞表演，人们在尝试不同的身份和性取向，非常颓废。
So he did not like that at all, this kind of progressive environment. I don't know, it sounds pretty cool to me. And outside of its politics, Hitler also hated the city on an aesthetic level. Berlin was kind of all over the place. It was the kind of epitome of modernism. You know, there was Bauhaus and all of these styles that Hitler despised. Hitler's disdain for progressive, modernist Berlin meant that the entire city would have to be rebuilt from scratch. Hitler even proposed that, once the complete urban redesign was finished, the city would be renamed Germania, a name that he believed evoked unity of the German people.
所以他一点也不喜欢这种进步的环境。我不知道，我觉得听起来挺酷的。除了政治之外，希特勒在审美层面上也讨厌这座城市。柏林到处都是。它是现代主义的缩影。你知道，有包豪斯和所有希特勒鄙视的风格。希特勒对进步的、现代主义的柏林的蔑视意味着整个城市必须从零开始重建。希特勒甚至提议，一旦完整的城市重新设计完成，这座城市将被更名为“日耳曼尼亚”（Germania），他认为这个名字唤起了德国人民的团结。
In 1937, Hitler gave Speer near complete control over all building projects throughout the city, and he was granted essentially unlimited budget and resources. Speer, as a matter of fact, had more power than anyone else when it came to building. So he always wanted more and more and more and bigger and bigger and bigger. This Berlin 2.0 was planned to be everything that the city was not. Rigidly symmetrical, ordered, devoid of color. And given Hitler's obsession with ancient Rome,
1937年，希特勒给了斯佩尔对全市所有建筑项目的近乎完全的控制权，并授予了他基本上无限的预算和资源。事实上，在建筑方面，斯佩尔拥有的权力比任何人都大。所以他总是想要更多、更多、更多，更大、更大、更大。这个“柏林2.0”计划成为这座城市所不是的一切。严格对称、有序、毫无色彩。考虑到希特勒对古罗马的痴迷，
the buildings would need to be stylistically reminiscent of Imperial Roman architecture. But these buildings wouldn't just be neoclassical. They would be monumental, meaning that the city would be built on a massive scale never before seen. I mean, that's, it's just huge. It says no sophistication. Magnus Brechtgen again. I mean, if we talk about architectural history and how architects think buildings, yeah,
这些建筑在风格上需要让人想起帝国罗马建筑。但这些建筑不仅仅是新古典主义的。它们将是纪念碑式的，意味着这座城市将以一种前所未有的巨大规模建造。我的意思是，这简直太巨大了。它没有任何精致感。再次请出马格努斯·布雷希特根。我的意思是，如果我们谈论建筑历史以及建筑师如何构思建筑，是的，
it's always about size to form, to function, to human dimension, and so on. Yeah. So it's a combination of finding the best formula when you build something. Yeah. And this is just to make people quiet, to impress them and to push with violent might away every kind of obstacle against your own ideological conviction. When it came to architecture, Speer did not put much thought into creating a satisfying user experience for those living there. Instead, he focused on how these buildings would propagandize Hitler's beliefs, how they would intimidate, and, surprisingly, how they would eventually
它总是关于形式、功能、人类尺度等等。是的。所以这是找到建造某物时的最佳公式的结合。是的。而这只是为了让人们安静下来，给他们留下深刻印象，并以暴力力量推开任何阻碍你自身意识形态信念的东西。在建筑方面，斯佩尔并没有花太多心思为居住在那里的人创造令人满意的用户体验。相反，他专注于这些建筑将如何宣传希特勒的信仰，它们将如何恐吓，以及令人惊讶的是，它们最终将如何
die. Yeah, it's the famous Ruin-en-Wert-Theorie, or Theorie des Ruin-en-Werts. He said the way he designed his buildings was with the foresight that in thousands of years they will just be ruins. Speer claimed to have conceived of a design principle that he called ruin value. Hitler and Speer believed that every empire comes to an end and the Third Reich would be no exception.
死亡。是的，这就是著名的“废墟价值理论”（Ruin-en-Wert-Theorie）。他说他设计建筑的方式是出于一种远见，即几千年后它们只会成为废墟。斯佩尔声称构思了一种他称之为“废墟价值”的设计原则。希特勒和斯佩尔相信每个帝国都会终结，第三帝国也不例外。
Hitler used to marvel at the ancient Roman ruins and he wanted civilizations of the future to do the same at his buildings. By avoiding materials like steel rebar and concrete facades, which tend to erode in an ugly way as they break down, he thought their monuments could decay more gracefully. That way, even after the Third Reich ended, their pretty, pretty ruins would pass on their racist
希特勒过去常对古罗马遗迹感到惊叹，他希望未来的文明也能对他的建筑做同样的事。通过避免使用钢筋和混凝土外墙等材料（这些材料在分解时往往会以丑陋的方式侵蚀），他认为他们的纪念碑可以更优雅地衰败。这样，即使在第三帝国结束后，他们漂亮的废墟也能在他们消失很久之后继续传递他们的种族主义
ideology long after they were gone. So a kind of antiquity was coming together with the past, the presence and the future were all becoming one. And that captures what the Nazis really believed. And yeah, so we're basically now on on top of this platform, which was built next to the Schwerbelastungskörper. And we're basically on the same height as the top of the heavy load bearing body. So we can kind of have the panoramic view of Berlin and also what the National Socialists were planning to do.
意识形态。所以一种古风与过去、现在和未来结合在一起，都融为一体了。这捕捉到了纳粹真正相信的东西。是的，所以我们现在基本上站在这个平台上，它建在Schwerbelastungskörper旁边。我们基本上和重载承重体的顶部处于同一高度。所以我们可以俯瞰柏林的全景，以及国家社会主义者计划要做的事情。
Back in the Tempelhof-Schöneberg district of Berlin, I followed Vincent Bruckmann up a platform about 14 meters above street level. This weird concrete cylinder I'd come to Berlin to see was marked as the starting point of Speer's proposed redesign for the city. It's really important to understand that everything, or most of what the National Socialists were planning, was not constructed. national socialists were planning was not constructed. Vincent showed me how Speer and Hitler planned for this Nazi megacity to be framed by two long intersecting axes.
回到柏林的滕珀尔霍夫-舍内贝格区，我跟着文森特·布鲁克曼走上了一个高出街道约14米的平台。我来到柏林要看的这个奇怪的混凝土圆柱体，被标记为斯佩尔提议的城市重新设计方案的起点。理解这一点非常重要：国家社会主义者计划的一切，或者大部分，都没有建成。文森特向我展示了斯佩尔和希特勒如何计划让这座纳粹超级城市被两条相交的长轴所框定。
One of which would be a quote, avenue of splendors that ran 4.3 miles from south to north. It would serve as a celebratory parade route. And looming at the end of this avenue would sit a structure that would define the city. This is basically where you can imagine, or the direction where you can imagine, this hall, Volkshalle Great Hall, Hall of the People, which was kind of the center of the plans. Years before he became leader of the Nazi party, Hitler sketched two architectural drawings that he one day wanted to build.
其中一条将是一条所谓的“辉煌大道”，从南到北延伸4.3英里。它将作为庆祝游行路线。在这条大道的尽头，将矗立着一座定义这座城市的建筑。这基本上就是你可以想象的地方，或者你可以想象的方向，这座“人民大厅”（Volkshalle），它是计划的中心。在成为纳粹党领袖的前几年，希特勒草绘了两幅他有一天想建造的建筑图纸。
The first was a colossal Volkshalle, or People's Hall. It would have been a massive neoclassical assembly space inspired by the Pantheon, only, you know, bigger. The Volkshalle featured a copper dome that towered nearly 88 stories high and would have fit up to 180,000 spectators inside. For reference, that's nine times more people than can fit in the Crypto.com arena. And they thought that even the there was kind of a microclimate within the hall if there
第一幅是巨大的“人民大厅”。它本应是一个受万神殿启发的大型新古典主义集会空间，只是，你知道，更大。人民大厅拥有一个高耸近88层楼的铜穹顶，内部可容纳多达18万名观众。作为参考，这比Crypto.com竞技场能容纳的人数多出九倍。他们甚至认为大厅内有一种微气候，如果
were I don't know 150, 180,000 people within there they were even thinking if there were I don't know condensation clouds and because there were just so many people in there, they were even thinking if there were, I don't know, condensation clouds, because there were just so many people in there. And you must imagine it was supposed to fit like almost 200,000 people, which is huge. It's just rain made of like sweat and spit and like breath. Yeah. Eww. Exactly.
有，我不知道，15万、18万人待在里面，他们甚至在想是否会有冷凝云，因为里面的人实在太多了。你必须想象它本应容纳近20万人，这太巨大了。那简直就是由汗水、唾液和呼吸组成的雨。是的。恶心。正是如此。
At the beginning of the parade route would be the other monument that Hitler sketched. It was a triumphal arch commemorating the German soldiers killed in World War I. Structurally, he wanted it to be reminiscent of the Arc de Triomphe in Paris. Only, you guessed it, bigger. This triumphal arch was planned as the southern gate to Germania, the new Berlin. And so all the tourists, international tourists, would have arrived at this train station in the south and then walked up to the arch. And then they would have seen in the distance on the other side of town this huge congregation hall. The buildings would be built on a scale never before seen in human history, which came with one very obvious
游行路线的起点将是希特勒草绘的另一座纪念碑。那是一座纪念第一次世界大战中阵亡的德国士兵的凯旋门。在结构上，他希望它让人想起巴黎的凯旋门。只是，你猜对了，更大。这座凯旋门被规划为“日耳曼尼亚”（新柏林）的南大门。所以所有的游客，国际游客，都会到达南部的这个火车站，然后走到拱门前。然后他们会在城镇的另一端看到这个巨大的集会大厅。这些建筑将以人类历史上前所未有的规模建造，这带来了一个非常明显的
structural engineering problem. There was no data supporting the fact, will the ground even carry these monstrous monuments? The ground in Berlin is very difficult to build on. The city sits on swampland, so it has mushy, gushy soil. You know what doesn't pair well with all that mushy, gushy soil? The weight of the largest buildings ever conceived. The Triumphal Arch in particular was exponentially more complicated because all of the weight of the entire monument would be concentrated onto narrow pillars.
结构工程问题。没有任何数据支持这一事实：地面甚至能承载这些巨大的纪念碑吗？柏林的地面非常难施工。这座城市坐落在沼泽地上，所以它有软绵绵的土壤。你知道什么和那些软绵绵的土壤不搭吗？有史以来构思出的最大建筑的重量。凯旋门尤其复杂，因为整个纪念碑的重量都将集中在狭窄的柱子上。
This meant that the ground pressure exerted by the arch would be incredibly intense. And if you want to build the biggest of everything, well, you need technological solutions for that. And Speer's technological solution was to build Schofam-Balanz-Korpor. Schwer-Balanz-Stund-Korpor. It's Schwer-Belastungskörper. So Schwer-Belastungskörper. In 1938, Speer was assigned to carry out any testing necessary to construct Hitler's mega monuments. And part of that testing was the construction of the Schwerbelastungskorper, that heavy concrete cylinder. The reason why it was so big and so heavy was because the weight of all that concrete
这意味着拱门施加的地面压力将极其强烈。如果你想建造最大的东西，好吧，你需要技术解决方案。而斯佩尔的技术解决方案就是建造Schwerbelastungskörper。是Schwerbelastungskörper。1938年，斯佩尔被指派进行建造希特勒超级纪念碑所需的任何测试。而测试的一部分就是建造Schwerbelastungskörper，那个沉重的混凝土圆柱体。它之所以如此巨大和沉重，是因为所有那些混凝土的重量
was supposed to simulate the pressure of one of the arches pillars pushing down onto the ground. Those 12,650 tons weigh more than the Eiffel Tower, the Statue of Liberty and the Christ the Redeemer statue combined. And also in terms of soil pressure, it even puts more pressure on the ground than the Kyob's pyramid in Egypt. So it is really extraordinarily heavy. Not much is known about the actual construction process of the cylinder. The Nazi party kept details of this megacity project under a tight lid, mainly because
本应模拟拱门柱子之一向下压向地面的压力。那12650吨的重量超过了埃菲尔铁塔、自由女神像和基督救世主雕像的总和。而且在土壤压力方面，它对地面的压力甚至超过了埃及的基奥普斯金字塔。所以它确实非常沉重。关于圆柱体的实际建造过程知之甚少。纳粹党对这个超级城市项目的细节严加保密，主要是因为
the complete reconstruction of Berlin would have demolished somewhere between 50 to 100,000 homes in the middle of a housing crisis. That was, of course, not even close to the worst consequence of Berlin's urban redesign. It was Jewish Berliners who were targeted first for deportation, and the labor and materials for the project would be supplied at a horrifically inhumane cost. There were a lot of people who suffered from it, for example, the Jewish population of
在住房危机期间，柏林的全面重建将拆除5万到10万套房屋。当然，这甚至还不是柏林城市重新设计最糟糕的后果。犹太裔柏林人首先成为驱逐的目标，而该项目的劳动力和材料将以极其不人道的代价提供。有很多人因此受苦，例如柏林的犹太人口，
Berlin, but also the forced laborers who had to build these projects and also the inmates of the concentration camps who were responsible for bringing the building material, for example, like the stones and the bricks. In 1941, the concrete cylinder was completed. But by that time, it didn't even matter anymore. The problem for the, air quotes, problem, air quotes, for the National Socialist was that the war started. And then there was the question of how to proceed. By this point, the US had entered World War II, and Hitler's makeover for Berlin would have to be tabled.
还有不得不建造这些项目的强迫劳工，以及负责运送建筑材料（例如石头和砖块）的集中营囚犯。1941年，混凝土圆柱体完工了。但到那时，这已经不再重要了。对于国家社会主义者来说，问题（引号）在于战争开始了。然后就是如何进行的问题。此时，美国已经参加了第二次世界大战，希特勒对柏林的改造计划不得不搁置。
Soon after, Speer was promoted from General Building Inspector to Minister of Armaments and Munitions. He was responsible for maximizing war production. So rather than using slave laborers to build Germania, he used them to produce weapons and war material for the German war effort. Speer was no longer an architect. It was his job to make sure the Third Reich could maintain its military operations. And it was a role that he was unfortunately very good at.
不久之后，斯佩尔从总建筑检查员晋升为军备和弹药部长。他负责最大限度地提高战争生产。因此，他没有使用奴隶劳工来建造“日耳曼尼亚”，而是用他们来为德国的战争努力生产武器和战争物资。斯佩尔不再是一名建筑师。他的工作是确保第三帝国能够维持其军事行动。这是一个他不幸非常擅长的角色。
He is responsible for keeping the war going for months on end when the war was lost and he knew that the war was lost. In the last year of the war, more people died than in the previous five years combined. Every day the war was prolonged. On average, more than 16,000 people died per day on every single day. So every day the war went on, another 16,000 people were killed. Speer knew this, and he went on regardless. The tribunal is of the opinion that Spears activities do not amount to initiating,
他负责在战争已经失败且他知道战争已经失败的情况下，让战争持续了数月之久。在战争的最后一年，死亡人数比过去五年的总和还要多。战争每延长一天，平均每天就有超过16000人死亡。所以战争每持续一天，又有16000人被杀。斯佩尔知道这一点，但他还是继续下去了。法庭认为斯佩尔的活动不构成发起、
planning or preparing wars of aggression or of conspiring to that end. He became the head of the arm and industry well after all the wars. In 1945, after the war ended, Albert Speer appeared before the court at Nuremberg along with 20 other National Socialist leaders. But over the course of his trial, Speer once again used his charm and charisma to get his way. He condemned Hitler and offered the Allied Council valuable details about how he achieved such a productive war economy for Germany. In the end, he was only sentenced to 20 years in prison.
计划或准备侵略战争，也不构成共谋。他在所有战争开始很久之后才成为军备和工业负责人。1945年战争结束后，阿尔伯特·斯佩尔与其他20名国家社会主义领导人一起出现在纽伦堡法庭。但在审判过程中，斯佩尔再次利用他的魅力和个人魅力达到了目的。他谴责了希特勒，并向盟军委员会提供了关于他如何为德国实现如此高效的战时经济的宝贵细节。最终，他仅被判处20年监禁。
I mean, he did spend 20 years in prison. Prison he was found guilty. But do you, in your opinion, did he get away with it? Yes, of course, of course. I think most people who knew what Speer had done and he himself knew what he had done, you see his reaction. There's a film when it's a reaction and he saw this kind of knew what he had done. You see his reaction.
我的意思是，他确实在监狱里待了20年。他被判有罪。但你认为，他逃脱惩罚了吗？是的，当然，当然。我想大多数知道斯佩尔所作所为的人，他自己也知道他做了什么，你看看他的反应。有一部电影，当他看到这种反应时，他知道自己做了什么。你看看他的反应。
There's a film when it's a reaction and he... So this kind of... Instinctively knew I'll survive. Yeah, sure, he got away with it, you know. While serving out his 20-year sentence, Speer authored a best-selling memoir about his time as, quote, Hitler's architect. He filled it with claims of remorse and left out the extent of the part he played in the
有一部电影，当他看到这种反应时，他……所以这种……本能地知道我会活下来。是的，当然，他逃脱了惩罚，你知道。在服完20年刑期期间，斯佩尔撰写了一本关于他作为“希特勒的建筑师”那段时光的畅销回忆录。他写满了悔恨的声明，却忽略了他在战争中扮演的角色。
war. By the time he was released from prison in 1966, some historians even referred to him as, quote, the good Nazi. Hitler said to me, you are my architect and you will do it for me. I was on the way to be one of the most famous architects in Europe. Speer and Hitler's monumental world capital was a city that never came to be. Almost no piece of architecture from this grand urban redesign of Berlin survived. Except one thing. It wasn't even possible to tear it down after the Second World War because it's too big.
当他在1966年出狱时，一些历史学家甚至称他为“好纳粹”。希特勒对我说，你是我的建筑师，你会为我做这件事。我正走在成为欧洲最著名建筑师的道路上。斯佩尔和希特勒的纪念碑式世界首都是一座从未实现的城市。柏林这次宏大的城市重新设计中，几乎没有任何建筑幸存下来。除了一件事。第二次世界大战后甚至无法拆除它，因为它太大了。
Albert Schweers concrete cylinder. What would it take to tear it down? A lot of... Was es Sprengstoff? Dynamite. A lot of dynamite. The Schwerbelastungs-Korpor was a 12,650 ton block of solid concrete in the middle of a city surrounded by residential buildings and train tracks. So blowing it up with explosives after the war was out of the question.
阿尔伯特·斯佩尔的混凝土圆柱体。拆除它需要什么？很多……是炸药吗？炸药。很多炸药。Schwerbelastungskörper是位于城市中心的一块12650吨重的实心混凝土块，周围环绕着住宅楼和铁轨。所以战后用炸药炸掉它是不可能的。
Berlin was sort of stuck with it. It wasn't really used by anybody and also, except the scientists, the engineers, no one really had any interest in it. This is Michael Richter, an architect and one of the leading historians of the Schwerbelastungskorpor. So it was more of a pragmatic approach to this building. Richter says that within just a few years of World War II ending, the German Society for Soil Mechanics picked up the geological research where the fascist structural engineers left off, only
柏林有点被它困住了。它并没有被任何人真正使用，而且除了科学家、工程师，没有人真正对它感兴趣。这是迈克尔·里希特，一位建筑师，也是Schwerbelastungskörper的主要历史学家之一。所以这更像是一种对这座建筑的务实方法。里希特说，在第二次世界大战结束后的几年内，德国土壤力学学会就在法西斯结构工程师停止的地方继续进行地质研究，只是
minus the fascism. For decades after the war, civilian scientists quietly used the cylinder to generate lots of data on how to build very big buildings on top of really squishy soil. It's actually been helpful for structural engineers all over the world. From 1948 to the middle of the 1980s, so much knowledge about the foundation was collected that the majority of what we have today... It also has a high scientific significance because a lot of the information that we know today about building in this kind of soil, we actually have from the research that has been done on this cylinder.
去掉了法西斯主义。战后几十年来，平民科学家悄悄地利用这个圆柱体产生了大量关于如何在非常松软的土壤上建造大型建筑的数据。它实际上对世界各地的结构工程师都有帮助。从1948年到80年代中期，收集了如此多关于地基的知识，以至于我们今天拥有的大部分……它也具有很高的科学意义，因为我们今天所知道的关于在这种土壤中建造的大部分信息，实际上都来自对这个圆柱体所做的研究。
So between 1948 and up until the mid-80s, the experiments that the engineers done on this cylinder. So between 1948 and up until the mid 80s, the experiments that the engineers did on this specific structure is where a lot of the information today comes from. Why is it that in the 1980s, it stopped being used? Keiner mehr, es hatte keiner mehr eine Frage. No one had any questions left. In 1983, having run out its use, the concrete cylinder was pretty much abandoned by researchers and fell into disrepair. It sat neglected for about a decade until the district realized that this space could
所以从1948年到80年代中期，工程师们在这个圆柱体上做的实验。所以从1948年到80年代中期，工程师们在这个特定结构上所做的实验，就是今天许多信息的来源。为什么它在80年代停止使用了？没有人再有任何问题了。1983年，由于失去了用途，这个混凝土圆柱体基本上被研究人员废弃，并陷入失修状态。它被忽视了大约十年，直到该区意识到这个空间可以
be of some use to teach people about what almost came of Berlin. The cylinder was listed as a protected monument in 1995, and today it's the only tangible relic of the National Socialist's master plan for Berlin. Even though it's a protected monument, the Schwerba-Lastenskörper was never built to last. It wasn't constructed with the best materials since it wasn't even supposed to be seen.
派上用场，向人们展示柏林差点变成了什么样。该圆柱体于1995年被列为受保护的纪念碑，今天它是国家社会主义者柏林总体规划中唯一有形的遗迹。尽管它是一座受保护的纪念碑，但Schwerbelastungskörper从来就不是为了持久而建造的。它不是用最好的材料建造的，因为它甚至不应该被看到。
So now the concrete is crumbling. The district has even had to set up netting around the outside of the cylinder so that chunks of it don't fall onto people's heads. I think it would be sad if this structure would not exist anymore, because I think actually it is a little embarrassing for the national Socialists because there are a few other things, but what is really visible from this planet Germania to changing this megalomanic world capital and then you come here and it's just basically this like concrete block. When Speer dreamed of the ruins his buildings would eventually become, he probably wasn't anticipating that they would be ruined so soon or take the form of this decaying concrete
所以现在混凝土正在崩塌。该区甚至不得不在圆柱体外围设置网，以免大块混凝土掉在人们头上。我想如果这座建筑不再存在会很悲哀，因为我认为它实际上对国家社会主义者来说有点尴尬，因为还有其他一些东西，但从这个“日耳曼尼亚”计划中真正可见的是改变这个狂妄自大的世界首都，然后你来到这里，它基本上只是这个混凝土块。当斯佩尔梦想着他的建筑最终会变成废墟时，他可能没有预料到它们会这么快就变成废墟，或者以这种腐烂的混凝土圆柱体的形式存在。
cylinder. But in a way, it's the perfect object to preserve Hitler's grand urban planning vision. There is no beauty. There is no beauty. There is no glory. It's just an ugly piece of history set in stone. More with Vivian after the break. So we are back with 99PI producer, Vivian Lay, who just brought us that story. Vivian, how are you doing?
但在某种程度上，它是保存希特勒宏大城市规划愿景的完美对象。没有美感。没有美感。没有荣耀。它只是刻在石头上的一段丑陋的历史。休息后继续与薇薇安交流。所以我们回到了《99PI》制作人薇薇安·莱身边，她刚刚给我们带来了那个故事。薇薇安，你怎么样？
I am exhausted, Roman. How are you? Thank you am exhausted, Roman. How are you? Thank you for asking, by the way. I'm okay. Yeah. Okay. Well, so what do you want to talk about today? Yeah.
我精疲力竭，罗曼。你怎么样？顺便问一下，谢谢你的关心。我还好。好的。好吧，那么你今天想谈什么？是的。
I don't know if I necessarily want to talk about this. It's just something that has to be addressed. But Roman, as you are aware, on the first day of his second term in office, Donald Trump issued a memorandum called Promoting Beautiful Federal Civic Architecture. It's basically at its core in order to promote the use of, quote, traditional and classical architecture for civic buildings. And this is something that he did back in 2020 at the end of his term, right? Yeah, yeah.
我不知道我是否一定要谈论这个。这只是必须解决的事情。但罗曼，正如你所知，唐纳德·特朗普在他第二个任期的第一天发布了一份名为“促进美丽的联邦公民建筑”的备忘录。它的核心基本上是要求促进在公民建筑中使用所谓的“传统和古典建筑”。这是他在2020年任期结束时做的事情，对吧？是的，是的。
So Donald Trump signed a version of this executive order in like the waning days of his first term in like December of 2020. I remember even back then everyone here at 99PI was like, what the fuck is he talking about? But Trump claims that the purpose of the order was to quote, uplift and beautify public spaces and ennoble the United States. Biden overturned it pretty much soon after he got into office in 2021, but now it is 2025 and we are back baby.
所以唐纳德·特朗普在他第一个任期结束时，大约在2020年12月签署了该行政命令的一个版本。我记得即使在当时，我们《99PI》的所有人都说，他在胡说八道什么？但特朗普声称该命令的目的是为了“提升和美化公共空间，并使美国高尚化”。拜登在2021年上任后不久就推翻了它，但现在是2025年，我们又回来了，宝贝。
So even back in 2020, what was Trump trying to accomplish with this order? So basically, Trump wants to make classical architecture the preferred style of all federal buildings. The founding fathers famously wanted the design of the Capitol to evoke ancient Greece and Rome. And so classical was the de facto style for about a century and a half, but of course, tastes change over time.
所以即使在2020年，特朗普试图通过这个命令实现什么？所以基本上，特朗普想让古典建筑成为所有联邦建筑的首选风格。国父们著名地希望国会大厦的设计能唤起古希腊和罗马的风格。因此，古典风格在过去一个半世纪里一直是事实上的风格，但当然，品味会随着时间而改变。
So in 1962, the GSA, which is the agency that oversees federal property, revised its guiding principles for federal architecture. And they stated that an official style should be avoided, and that, quote, design must flow from the architectural profession to the government and not vice versa. And so you see that the most common style for federal buildings built between the 1950s and the 1970s actually was brutalism and Roman you and I both know that brutalism has been a very divisive style for a very long time. For sure, for sure. Someone else who apparently hates it is, of course, Donald Trump.
所以1962年，负责监督联邦财产的机构GSA修订了其联邦建筑指导原则。他们声明应避免使用官方风格，并且“设计必须从建筑专业流向政府，而不是反之亦然”。所以你会看到，1950年到1970年间建造的联邦建筑最常见的风格实际上是粗野主义，罗曼，你和我都知道，粗野主义长期以来一直是一种非常有争议的风格。当然，当然。显然也讨厌它的人，当然是唐纳德·特朗普。
And his argument is that we in this country have stopped building beautiful buildings. An early draft for the 2020 executive order was actually titled, quote, making federal buildings beautiful again, which is very on the nose. Right. I mean, it's pretty much echoing the rhetoric that Trump always says, which is about America returning to greatness. So returning to a classical style of architecture in his eyes is the return to the glory of the past. Yes. Now, if you listen to the story that we just played, you might already into it
他的论点是，我们这个国家已经停止建造美丽的建筑了。2020年行政命令的初稿实际上标题为“让联邦建筑再次美丽”，这非常直白。对。我的意思是，这几乎是在呼应特朗普总是说的关于美国回归伟大的言论。所以在他眼中，回归古典建筑风格就是回归过去的荣耀。是的。现在，如果你听了我们刚刚播放的故事，你可能已经察觉到
why many people are concerned with this particular rhetoric. Critics have argued that when the far right and or white supremacists push for a return to quote traditional values of classical architecture, they specifically mean a return to the values of traditionally white, traditionally European, traditionally Christian heritage, and the styles that deviate from that are bad. Right. And since these federal buildings are the buildings that represent the United States, it's easy to see how the arguments against diverse architectural styles are arguments
为什么许多人对这种特定的言论感到担忧。批评者认为，当极右翼和/或白人至上主义者推动回归所谓的“古典建筑的传统价值观”时，他们特别指的是回归传统白人、传统欧洲、传统基督教遗产的价值观，而偏离这些风格的都是坏的。对。而且由于这些联邦建筑是代表美国的建筑，很容易看出反对多样化建筑风格的论点就是
against diversity writ large. Yes. It's very culture war, but make it architecture. This has basically become a debate about what American identity is supposed to look like. Yeah, yeah. So there's been a lot of noise on either side of this order, but I'm curious what the real world impacts are
反对多样性本身的论点。是的。这非常像文化战争，但把它变成了建筑。这基本上已经变成了一场关于美国身份应该是什么样子的辩论。是的，是的。所以在这个命令的两边有很多噪音，但我很好奇现实世界的影响是什么
of this executive order, because actually there's not a lot of federal buildings being built at any one moment. Yes. What does it actually mean? So, like, first of all, I do think that putting limitations on creativity is bad. Also who is Trump to define what beauty is. To be sure. Yes. I have seen his buildings.
这个行政命令的影响，因为实际上在任何时刻都没有建造很多联邦建筑。是的。它到底意味着什么？所以，首先，我确实认为限制创造力是不好的。而且特朗普是谁，他有什么资格定义什么是美。当然。是的。我见过他的建筑。
They are hideous. Yes. But, you know, I will admit that this so far hasn't been the most consequential move he's made since getting back into office, mostly because he's done so many terrible things. As of recording this, the GSA is facing much bigger problems. So we will have to see, you know, how this will be implemented. There has been some speculation that one thing it could have a direct impact on is the J. Edgar Hoover building, which is FBI headquarters.
它们很丑。是的。但是，你知道，我承认到目前为止，这并不是他回到办公室后做出的最有影响力的举动，主要是因为他做了太多可怕的事情。在录制这段节目时，GSA正面临更大的问题。所以我们将不得不看看，你知道，这将如何实施。有一些猜测认为，它可能产生直接影响的一件事是J·埃德加·胡佛大楼，也就是联邦调查局总部。
It's this big blocky, brutalist concrete building with these perfectly aligned square windows and it kind of looks like a house of waffles. Like not a waffle house, but like a house made out of waffles. So, it has apparently been falling apart for quite some time. And the plan has been to rebuild a new facility in Greenbelt, Maryland, but Trump has been very vocal about this, posting in all caps, the new FBI building should be built in Washington, DC, not Maryland, and be the centerpiece of my plan to totally renovate and rebuild our capital city into the most beautiful and safest anywhere in the world.
这是一座巨大的、粗野主义风格的混凝土建筑，有着排列整齐的方形窗户，看起来有点像华夫饼屋。不是那种连锁店“华夫饼屋”，而是像用华夫饼盖成的房子。显然，它已经破败很久了。原本的计划是在马里兰州的格林贝尔特重建一个新设施，但特朗普对此直言不讳，他用全大写字母发帖称，新的联邦调查局大楼应该建在华盛顿特区，而不是马里兰州，并应成为他全面翻新和重建我们首都计划的核心，使其成为世界上最美丽、最安全的地方。
So there's that, that might be directly impacted by this. Yeah, that is very reminiscent to the story we just heard. I mean, to me, what is interesting is that the stories behind these design choices, they're all kind of based on non-truths. I mean, what we see in the main story and from this executive order is a kind of cherry picking of history that is just wrong. I mean, what Hitler and Trump and even
所以就是这样，这可能会直接受到影响。是的，这非常让人想起我们刚才听到的故事。对我来说，有趣的是，这些设计选择背后的故事，它们在某种程度上都是基于非事实的。我的意思是，我们在主故事和这项行政命令中看到的是一种对历史的断章取义，这完全是错误的。我的意思是，希特勒、特朗普，甚至
the founding fathers, what they did was kind of use architecture to tell kind of incorrect and pretty much ahistoric version of what the past was like. I mean, ancient Greece did not look like the white austere Lincoln Memorial. It was full of color and it was chaotic and just the paint just wore away. And so we see it as sort of monochromatic and sort of has this sort of like a gust bearing, but like it really was a mix of things. So not only is it sort of problematic in its execution,
开国元勋们，他们所做的是利用建筑来讲述一种不准确且几乎是反历史的过去版本。我的意思是，古希腊看起来并不像白色、朴素的林肯纪念堂。它充满了色彩，而且是混乱的，只是油漆褪去了。所以我们把它看作是单色的，有一种庄严感，但它实际上是多种事物的混合体。所以它不仅在执行上是有问题的，
it's also just kind of just wrong on the face of it, which is sort of, you know, I don't know. I don't know if that's the most important part of it. Maybe the values are more important than them being wrong about it. But it's still like it's doubly wrong. Yes. And, you know, I will say that the debate with classical architecture today, it's become more of a political battle than about aesthetics at this point. And I don't necessarily think that if you think that the Parthenon looks nice, that you are a racist, or if you hate the FBI headquarters,
而且从表面上看也是错误的，这有点，你知道，我不知道。我不知道这是否是最重要的部分。也许价值观比他们在这件事上犯错更重要。但这仍然是双重错误。是的。而且，我想说的是，今天关于古典建筑的辩论，在这一点上已经变成了一场政治斗争，而不是美学之争。我不一定认为如果你觉得帕台农神庙看起来不错，你就是一个种族主义者，或者如果你讨厌联邦调查局总部，
you know, it doesn't mean that you're not progressive. But the thing that I've run into over and over again, while reporting the story, is that you're not progressive. But the thing that I've run into over and over again while reporting the story is that architecture is always political. And you can't separate the two. So what you build, where you build it, who's it for, and how it expresses your values, it's all political, man. That's right.
你知道，这并不意味着你不是进步派。但在报道这个故事时，我一次又一次遇到的事情是，你不是进步派。但在报道这个故事时，我一次又一次遇到的事情是，建筑永远是政治性的。你无法将两者分开。所以你建造什么、在哪里建造、它是为谁建造的，以及它如何表达你的价值观，这一切都是政治，伙计。没错。
That's right. So yeah, I totally agree. When I go to Washington, DC and I see the Capitol building in particular, like, it awes me. Like, it does the job that it's supposed to do. And I think that is a great and noble thing to feel like this sense of, of like permanence and strength and all that stuff that's centered on the US Capitol building. Like I totally feel those things. So there's nothing wrong with that. But if somebody comes up to you, like one of these trad architecture bros comes and talks to you about the values of traditional
没错。所以是的，我完全同意。当我去华盛顿特区看到国会大厦时，我感到敬畏。它确实发挥了它应有的作用。我认为，感受到这种以美国国会大厦为中心的永恒感、力量感等等，是一件伟大而高尚的事情。我完全能感受到这些。所以这没什么错。但如果有人走过来，比如那些传统建筑的拥护者，跟你谈论传统建筑的价值观，
architecture, man, turn on your heel and walk the other direction. Because that point of view is a linked trait to a bunch of even more horrible ideas and ideologies. So just walk away. For sure. Thank you, Vivian. Thanks, Roman. and APM, Fact Checking by Graham Haysha. Translation and Tapesync by Sara Zerreya Houshariecha. Special thanks this week to Paul Kurek and the Berlin Underworlds Association.
伙计，转身走开。因为那种观点与一系列更可怕的思想和意识形态有着内在联系。所以走开就行了。当然。谢谢你，薇薇安。谢谢，罗曼。以及APM，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙负责。翻译和录音同步由萨拉·泽雷亚·胡沙里查负责。本周特别感谢保罗·库雷克和柏林地下世界协会。
Cathy Tu is our Executive Producer, Kurt Kolstad is the Digital Director, Delaney Hall is our Senior Editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Dawn, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family.
凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什玛·道恩、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我，罗曼·马斯。99%的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员。
Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us all on Blue Sky. That's where we're meeting with the public these days, as well as our own Discord server where we have like private discussions about the power broker, about architecture, about flags, about this and these days, as well as our own Discord server, where we have private discussions about the Power Broker,
现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心以北六个街区的潘多拉大楼。你们可以在Blue Sky上找到我们。那是我们最近与公众见面的地方，还有我们自己的Discord服务器，我们在那里进行关于《权力掮客》、建筑、旗帜的私人讨论，关于这个，以及最近，还有我们自己的Discord服务器，我们在那里进行关于《权力掮客》的私人讨论，
about architecture, about flags, about this and that. There's a link to that Discord server, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. I know this, I need to get, I literally can't do this. Schofam balans skorpor. Shwer balans tans skorpor. Shwer balans tans skorpor. Shwer balans tans skorpor. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于建筑、旗帜、关于这个和那个。在99PI.org上有通往那个Discord服务器的链接，以及99PI的每一集往期节目。我知道这个，我需要得到，我真的做不到。Schofam balans skorpor. Shwer balans tans skorpor. Shwer balans tans skorpor. Shwer balans tans skorpor. 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。